[Musik]
wir sind auf dem weg nach münchen an der
bundeswehr universität untersucht
professor schau mit seinem forscherteam
micro plastik autoreifen fasern in der
kleidung schuhe oder kosmetikartikel
sie verlieren alle diese synthetische
material das in die umwelt gelangt über
viele wege zum beispiel über abwasser
christian schauer forscht daher den
klärschlamm wo sich micro plastik
ansammelt wenn man sich anschaut wie
weit sind wir heute in der forschung und
was wissen wir darüber muss man sich
vorstellen
es existieren sehr starke bilder in den
kopf von verendeten vögeln und fischen
mit großen plastikteilen in netzen
verfangen aus dem marinen bereich
wir sprechen ja wirklich über mikro
plastik partikel über kleinste partikel
wenn sie eine wasserflasche sehen würden
würden sie ja gar kein partikel erstmal
sehen als sie bräuchten ja schon je
nachdem wie weit man runter geht ja
schon einen hub an kroos coop dafür um
es letztendlich zu identifizieren und
die herausforderung besteht ganz
sicherlich daran und das ist das was für
uns intensiv momentan beschäftigen
die fragestellung wie nehme ich eine
probe wie muss sich die probe
aufbereiten und dann letztendlich zum
schluss auf überhaupt auf eine analytics
zu kommen und das ist momentan eher die
herausforderung in dem system
die geräte dürfen nicht aus plastik sein
da die probe sonst kontaminiert werden
könnte erklärt der professor
die filter sind daher aus edelstahl
da sehen sie dass der aufwand corp und
der filter dass das filtersystem sitzen
wir drauf und es doch letztendlich
eingebaut und filtriert das wasser
dementsprechend dementsprechend muss das
wasser mit dem die spülen um das normal
in dem bewusstsein zu haben und die
chemikalien müssen jetzt endlich auch
alle micro plastik frei sein
in dem system und werden bei uns
dementsprechend alle auch noch mal
vibriert bevor sie eingesetzt werden
angefangen von dem verbraucherverhalten
im haushalt über die fragestellung wie
sind die antragsphase und wie gelangt
eine plastik in die aquatische umwelt
und dann letztendlich daraus bewertungs
und handlungsstrategien zu entwickeln
micro plastik zu vermeiden und ein ganz
entscheidender punkt dabei ist
letztendlich zu schauen wie verhält sich
plastik dort im alterungs verhalten und
welche zusatzstoffe additive werden
freigesetzt die letztendlich dann auch
eine humane und ökotoxikologie wirkung
haben können und diese aspekte alle
fließen letztendlich ein in einen sohn
und bewertungs tool mit der idee ansätze
für ein gütesiegel zu haben wie können
kunststoffe bewertet werden im hinblick
auf den umgang in der aquatischen oben
willst aber wie schwer ist das für sie
in diesem aspekt dann festzustellen und
zu forschen wenn sie wissen dass die
gemische von plastik sich permanent
verändern das ist die herausforderung
und das ist tatsächlich auch dass der
schwierige konstrukt nehmen wir uns
stellen müssen
somit ist letztendlich ein system womit
wir beginnen und man immer wieder noch
exemplarische rein kunststoffe quasi im
untersucht aber natürlich bleibt es eine
ein konstrukt den man erst mal verfolgt
wir versuchen uns mit möglichst nahe
anzunehmen um zu schauen wie es vor
allen dingen welche kundschaft werden
überwiegend verbraucht als über die über
die die mengen verteilung letztendlich
auch aber klar also es ist es ist
letztendlich dort ein fokusthema mit
hinein geht aber nicht die ganze welt so
überspitzt gefragt läuft die forschung
der industrie hinterher
wir haben assoziierte partner die die
industrie mit dabei sind und somit
stellen wir letztendlich sicher dass
diese neueren wechseln auch mit
einfließen und somit glaube ich ist es
erstmal so nicht direkt der fall
nichtsdestotrotz wenn sie schauen wieder
einen kunststoffe eingesetzt werden
und heute diskutieren wir und davor
schon wir das thema wie plastik so ein
stück weit laufen wie selbstverständlich
hinterher was hier sehen können bei frau
melanie dass sie genau dort in den
besser gläsern vor schlammproben hat und
sie sehen dort auch relativ eindrücklich
dass es eben eine echte herausforderung
ist in solchen medien micro plastik
partikel zu analysieren ist ein palace
wo rauch ist andere produkte hergestellt
werden aus der genau aus der industrie
und jetzt habe ich einfach mal ist ein
test dass man sich man sieht wie
unterschiedlich kunststoffe sein können
und zwar an die unterschiedliche dichten
sie sehen hier oben sehr leichte
kunststoffe und es gibt auch stoffe die
eine höhere dichte haben und sich danach
heil unten ablagen den haben wir direkt
vom volk um abgezogen und das ist für
mich mit ein grund medium um meine
versuche jetzt momentan durchzuführen
das sind zur und land versuche einfach
mal zu testen was passiert wenn ich
jetzt 28 tage diese pellets sind er
unterschiedliche sieht man ja auch
unterschiedliche fahrer unterschiedliche
form passierte was das ist jetzt so
erstmal so der grundaufbau um dann
später zugucken wenn es sich die
veränderungen sind warum wieso weshalb
passiert so was
das haben sie schon mit
diese 28 tage wir sind noch dabei
wir haben ja im projekt kastrat
verschiedene kunststoffe und jetzt sind
wir dabei die immer zu testen und wo wir
natürlich was sehen werden wir auch
länger versuche durch das heißt es kann
sein dass die eigenschaften von diesem
micro plastik teilten sich verändern
können das ist natürlich gegenstand der
forschung das könnte sein kann nicht
sein aber das ist das was was sich
momentan unter war ja jetzt schon dinge
die sie festgestellt haben oder wo sie
fest davon ausgehen dass die zu treffen
hat das ist da sind wir wirklich in den
kinderschuhen und insofern ist es jetzt
schwer mond haben überhaupt etwas
mitzuteilen dass laufen untersuchen
das forscherteam ist mitten in der
untersuchungsphase für ergebnisse ist es
aber noch zu früh
[Musik]